Jermaine Fowler made a smooth move from
stand up to sitcoms he paid his comedy
dues dues rather on stages in New York
City he went on to create and star in
the sketch comedy series Friends of the
people he also headlined his own
stand-up special on Showtime called give
him hell kid now in his in executive
producer in star of superior doughnuts
which is right here on CBS it's a comedy
that also comments on social issues hey
hey she risks her life every day out
there in my book that's a hero would you
stop saying it you know you didn't even
see the video so until you do you don't
get an opinion Franco I thought we were
past this
Randi if I'm gonna be your friend I'm
gonna be real with you I still think
what you did was messed up and I almost
become I go these are the corrupt cops
in Chicago who crossed the line so much
they don't know where it is anymore I
just totally forgot what was right down
Jermaine Fowler joins us at the table
talk about being topical because Katie
plays a cop on the show he's a golf and
she's involved in a dispute mm-hmm with
someone that you know and you look at
the tape and you look at her very
differently yeah I think it's
interesting that you're tackling such a
current topical issue in my comedy I
think you should I think you should you
know comedies for still you know we
reflect the world you know and I mean
that's what we're supposed to be doing
Franco discovers his tape that it pretty
much displays Randy to Luke katey sagal
being overly aggressive with the friend
of his you know during a traffic stop
and pretty much questions she's a good
cop or a bad cop it's eating him up
really eat him up that's one of the
scenes it all blows up right in front of
their faces but they stand up a good
training for a sketch comedy or
situation comedy yeah I mean you know I
that's where I got my my start
I started stand-up when I was a 17 18
years old after watch Eddie Murphy raw
yeah VHS tape I loved it so much and I
just used it as a way to you know talk
about my life you know where I was going
through my area I'm from Hyattsville
Maryland and you know what it was like
growing up there you know it was just
right for comedy and I'm glad I did
because it was very therapeutic at the
same time what at the heart of a good
joke the heart of a good joke truth
honesty even if people don't like it or
don't agree with you
it's just the earnestness and the honest
'no set you have that people can that
makes it endearing
you know Patrice O'Neal's are my
favorite stand-ups and people he's
probably one of the most you know
polarizing people you would ever meet
but the man was honest about himself and
that's what you could appreciate about
so there's four stand-up comedians on
the cast of yeah gotta be fine non-stop
jokes on sale you know it's hard to hone
his back in to act you know minutes like
yeah we gotta activate my bad sorry
about that Judd because judges like
Broadway you know but Judge funny
himself judge hilarious man it's good
director to and would kind of cultivate
that maybe you know is the neighbor say
alright I'm actually will use that yes
you know stand up in multicam sitcoms
they marry each other very well you know
Martin did stand up he was you know he's
the you know he's the man you know I
mean Martin was my favorite children
Martin Lawrence yeah doing live shows
you know in the stand-up world sort of
just you know they and multicam they
marry each other very well because I do
stand-up and I'm used to doing the
audience shows and I get to hear the
immediate reaction so I just know what
jokes on the live shows are gonna work
and what's not and from the acting world
you know I go do stand-up I'm just more
confident playing characters on stage
but you do most of the people you know
who do stand-up comedy are sort of funny
by nature yeah you know it's not
something they'd necessarily learn you
can't you can't teach someone how to
formulate a joke like making it funny is
different you know timing you can teach
probably timing Tommy you can't teach
time and that's just something that's in
you like Mitch Hedberg and you know
Pryor and the marina Franklin and Greer
fallens they're all from New York
they're amazing they're my favorite most
like paste comics I've ever seen I've
learned a lot watching those two when
Judd Hirsch was here though you should
know there's Jermaine he was raving
about you he said they look so quick
yeah you were so funny that it's hard to
keep up with you he was he was he's
really saying your praises and what's
interesting about your background is in
high school you recall the class clown
but you don't like that time you know
what I never liked being called class
clown because my mom rest in peace my
mom told me is your man you don't want
people to laugh at you you're gonna
laugh with you you don't want to be a
clown you want
I'm sorry anyone who was a clown sorry I
ain't no professional clown I'm so sorry
I just I just never wanted to be one so
when I got nominated class clown in
school I remember my mom said don't be
no clown so I went to my vice principal
of my school I said can we change this
your mom passed away in August you do
lazy moms we had a baby girl in July
yeah like the circle of life circle of
life yeah man I it's insane you know but
some of them um spirit sort of just you
know sleep them out you know to the baby
and it was a cool to see how much and my
mom she you know she sort of exudes you
know she's gonna give you new material
Jermaine I agree thank you very much I
appreciate that Alavi
you can watch the season premiere of
superior doughnuts it's Monday night at
9:00 8:00 central right here on CBS